if you are heartbroken about what's going on in Gaza
there are ways that you can directly help families
there's a project called Olive Branch
which I'm sure um
many of you have been seeing in your feeds
thanks to amazing creators who have been drawing attention to it
they have this incredible spreadsheet
where you can get involved in so many different ways
what they're encouraging people to do
no matter what your following is
is to choose and sponsor a family and encourage people to support and uh
donate to their fund
in uh
their disability column they uh
drew attention to Ibrahim
who is a psychologist who has worked with a lot of autistic children in Gaza
he has an autistic daughter
and I have decided to support their fund in order for them to escape
any of the donations are $5
so I know that people are really strapped right now
and I totally understand if you are not in a financial situation uh
or position to make a donation
but every dollar counts
he is still trying to offer um
support to autistic children who are being displaced right now
his daughter needs medication and they cannot return to their home
even when he was trying to evacuate
he was still providing services for autistic children who are being displaced
and who as you can probably imagine
need so much support right now
this is the centre that he created in Gaza for children with disabilities
they need our support in order to keep providing those services
if you can't afford um
the donation you can go to his Instagram
follow um
like and engage with his videos
so that more people can come across them and support him and the center
I will put the link for the gofundme in my bio
if you can't afford it right now um
send it to someone who you think might be able to
so much that we can do in order to support children um
and families right now
so again uh
go to Olive Branch
you'll find tons of ways of getting involved
thank you for listening until the end of this video I love you